ننتقل واياكم لمشاهده هذه الصور المباشره
لمتظاهرين اوكرانيين من امام الفندق الذي
يقيم به الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن في وارسو
ويطالبونه بارسال مقاتله اف 16
لاوكرانيا كما يظهر في هذه اللافتات
امامنا اذا وقفه امام مقر اقامه بايدن في
العاصمه البولنديه وارسو التي يزورها
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن هذه الايام
يطالبونه بارسال مقاتلات اف 16 لاوكرانيا
كان الرئيس زلينسكي ايضا قد طلب من نظيره
الامريكي ارسال صواريخ بعيده المدى وكذلك
ايضا مقاتلات
في هذه
الايام التي يزور فيها طبعا الرئيس جو
بايدن بولندا وزاره قبل ذلك كييف منذ
يومين من الان ومع اقتراب الذكرى السنويه
الاولى للعمليه العسكريه الخاصه الروسيه
في اوكرانيا وهذه مطالبات بارسال السيد
بايدن ارسل اف 16 كما يظهر في هذه طبعا
اللافته الكبيره من امام مقر اقامه الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن في وارسو
كما ذكرنا المطالبه بارسال هذه المقاتله
الى اوكرانيا مقاتله اف 16 التي يطلبها
المحتجون من امام المقر الذي يقيم فيها
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن نحن نعلم طبعا
بان الحلفاء الاوروبيين ايضا في النيتو
لم يتوصلوا الى اي اتفاق حتى هذه اللحظه
حول ارسال صواريخ بعيده المدى او مقاتلات
ايضا هناك تحفظ من بعض هذه الدول
بالولايات المتحده ايضا اكتفت بارسال
صواريخ جافلين وكذلك
صواريخ هاي مارس الامريكيه متوسطه المدى
لم يتم الاعلان حتى هذه اللحظه
ارسال مقاتلات بعيده المدى او حتى طائرات
اف 16 لذلك نرى هذه الوقفه والتظاهر من
قبل بعض الاوكران امام مقر اقامه الرئيس
الامريكي في وارسو للمطربه بارسال اف 16